first proof that psychedelics don't
eliminate your brain they actually they
may give you insights into Humanity
you're removing yourself from what Blake
called Mind forged manacles you know and
Huxley of course uses that Blake
quotation about the doors of perception
being cleansed and we'd see reality for
what it is Limitless five meodmt is one
of the most potent psychedelics known to
mankind for research reasons I had to
take some
and um
foreign
[Music]
okay I've got a candidate for not the
way to go forward which is I was reading
about in the University of Florida some
a researcher discovered that if you um
there's this poor creature called the
South American cane toad and there was
this experiment where if you lick the
head of this poor toad a couple of times
you've got a sort of equivalent to an
acid trip so I think we shouldn't go
forward with the South American cane
toad I think that's probably not much
fun for the toad I mean we should think
about the Toad's experience
but I think I was quite interested
actually this is to add a kind of again
I suppose in terms of the philosophical
aspect of the debate you know all of
these new smart drugs and the nootropic
drugs again sort of coming from nouse
you know news the kind of idea of mind
and the sort of possibility then that
you can have this sort of perfectable
high-performing mind which has a
brilliant memory and it's obviously
doing brilliant work with narcolepsy and
with ADHD and with really serious
conditions Alzheimer's but if you push
that into a more kind of you know who's
going to control decisions about you
know how improved the Mind might be you
know is it going to become normative
then to have amazing powers of focus and
Consciousness and if you don't want to
do that you become like someone in you
know on the west coast of America who
doesn't want plastic surgery or that
sort of that you know kind of so this
really interesting adaptation of the
Mind through these kinds of drugs and
where that will go and whether you're in
kind of Brave New worlds which Huxley
writes in 1932 where he says Soma is
kind of a bit worrying and creepy or
whether you're in his final novel post
masculine which he writes in 1962 Island
where he says actually you know you can
have quite a nice Society if people have
access to a sort of you know benign jug
that makes them feel better so it's a
real question of which again which
future you end up in
foreign
[Music]
you can have psychedelic experiences
that
of course distort reality I mean if they
they make this metal rod look like it's
kind of fluctuating and you know that's
a that could be an interesting
experience and might teach you a few
things but it wouldn't be accurate
wouldn't be correct
um then of course there might be things
that it reveals that are completely
consistent with things that you already
know and they're just being revealed to
you by that experience that's also a
great and good
um so um but as I say the the issue of
is there a single reality
to which all of our thought is
um
responsive
or responsible
is only joined if you think that there
are two descriptions of reality
incompatible with one another that are
both true yeah exactly so it is this
feeling of real of reality right that is
so disturbing that it makes you doubt
yes now there is a there is a feeling of
reality there is that absolutely and you
can sometimes have it when it's not real
as in dreams or psychedelic experiences
um now the relevance of that is not so
much to the question of Truth and
relativism but it is to the question of
knowledge how we know what is true how
we know what is a fact because if you
can have this feeling of reality when in
fact it's misleading
you can get into the standard classical
skeptical problem of how do I know that
that's not happening right now
I have the strong feeling of reality
things seem very consistent I think to
be sitting here talking to you
but maybe that's not real right so the
classical skepticism is not uh is is a
real problem it's not dismissable it
doesn't raise any question about
relativism it doesn't raise any question
about truth
in fact presupposes that there is truth
and it's objective and the question is
how we know what it is you get much
worse skeptical the more of an
objectivist you are about truth the more
skepticism you will have to deal with
thank you
foreign
[Music]
was my first of 19 first term at
University having a great time and I was
seriously sleep deprived from having
such a great time and staying up too
late and getting to nine o'clock
lectures and all that and went back to a
friend's room late had a little bit of a
smoke listening to some music anyway
there I am listening to this music sat
on the floor uh two friends with me and
I start going down a tunnel that was
that on the left is the drawing that I
made of the tunnel um a little while
later it was a tunnel of trees a tunnel
of leaves there were leaves all around
and it was kind of autumnal it was sort
of orange and brown and I was zooming
around down this you know leaves and
trees flashing pasta like sort of
galloping horse noises
um whenever I walk in the woods and I
see a tunnel like that it takes me back
to that experience well I'd never heard
of tunnel experiences I'm going down the
tunnel and my friend said to me where
are you sue
ask yourself that question now where are
you
what happens you immediately go I'm
doing well I'm here and there's a 10 you
know whatever at least I think that's
what happens to you and I tried to do
that and I was like really confused and
I thought well I'm in Vicky's room and
you know and then everything kind of
cleared I'd been feeling very drifty and
weird and everything suddenly cleared
and there I was looking down on the room
from above
and it was quite extraordinary
everything looked completely Vivid and
totally like wow more Vivid than Vivid
more real than real it was really really
amazing this is interesting for many
reasons
um dualist ideas have been around a very
long time that's a an Egyptian um
ancient Egyptian depiction of the bar
leaving the the body at death
um there's a astral projection Theory
modern near-death experiences I'm not
going to be talking about near-death
experiences today but you get the outer
body experience is a part of a classic
near-death experience and these are all
dualist ideas and of course the
religions the major the major faiths
could not exist without some kind of
dualist belief I mean the the threats of
hell and the promises of Heaven would
not work and entrap people in religious
belief if it weren't for the natural
belief in dualism
um because without dualism there's
nothing to survive and you know well
there are other possibilities perhaps we
can come back to that later but it's
kind of fundamental and little kids from
very young age start to become think
dualistically they first distinguish
living from non-living things and then
thinking from non-thinking things and so
on
um so this is kind of embedded in it so
I agree with metzinger that
um that's what would happen and that's
what happened to me I just thought wow
this proves that my soul or my mind or
something my Consciousness has left my
body this proves life after death this
proves telepathy Clairvoyance
psychokinesis precognition you know
anything
um uh like that that was the conclusions
I jumped to
foreign
[Music]
just to talk you through visually what's
happening so in the normal situation
your brain reconstructs those light and
Sensations that come into your retina
and it reconstructs into images but
under under psychedelics it can't
it can't organize them in the way it's
always organized them and that's why you
see things differently
and what's actually interesting and this
is what is remarkable
in 1954
two scientists from MIT
predicted they may wrote a paper called
what the Frog's eye tells the Frog's
brain
that's what frogs see that's the very
low level processing of your visual
quantity the only time you can actually
see how your brain the brain visual
system works is under psychedelics
because the build up to make the full
images broken down so you actually see
the early processing which is again a
very interesting Concept in neuroscience
but the other thing that happens if you
take away the control centers
the brain can connect in ways it's not
allowed to the process as you probably
know those of you who've got kids are
really engaged in this hard you've got
to make kids do the same thing all the
time otherwise they end up being very
difficult you know they've got to speak
the same
glass has to mean the same thing every
time you have to always learn you know
systematically to be part of the human
Community everything's got to be
organized and that means that the brain
becomes very good and very efficient at
doing Simple Things
uh repeatedly and when we image the
brain in a normal State we see that most
of the activity of the brain is Round
The Edge bits of the brain involving
hearing talk to hearing and bits of the
brain involved in singing talk to scene
but there's not a lot of
cross-connectivity
this is called the small world version
of the brain we've education is about
parcelation it's about putting into
the periphery of the brain the processes
which make it easy for you to live your
lives
but under psychedelics
those this small world versus the brain
breaks down and there's much more
connectivity both of these images have
exactly the same number the 7 200
Connections in each
but normally it's
it's very localized very constrained
very traditional under psychedelics
connections can be made which are never
allowed
in your brain except since since you've
been one or two years old you've been
denied those access and that's and this
break the breaking down of connections
gives people insights which they've
never had before and that's one of the
reasons these drugs are powerful not
just in terms of changing people's
political mindsets but also dealing with
disorders where you might have excessive
um
rigidity of thinking like depression or
OCD so we did the first ever Imaging
study of LSD ever in the world we found
the same thing LSD switches off the
parts of the brain which control brain
function in the same way as psilocybin
and the more you switch off the
connectivity between this part of the
brain which I don't want to go into and
your memory the more more you feel
you're not part of yourself the more you
feel you're part of the universe
and also if we show for the first time
why people have such interesting visual
hallucinations with their eyes closed
under rather steep
because normally as I explained the
small world brain the visual cortex just
talks to itself
a little little bit of conversation with
the memory Center here under LSD the
visual system can connect to anywhere
and that's why people have seen such
interesting things under LST because
they're for the first time as I say
since they were babies the brain has
been liberated so they'd actually you
can make connections again
just very briefly I want to just show
you it's the psychedelics are very
different from any other drug this is a
technique called maggots like EG they
just shows the very beautiful sort of
fingerprint way the difference between
psychedelics over here which switch off
the brain and drugs over here like
anesthetics which lock the brain into a
state of complete synchronicity which is
very uh
unhelpful in terms of thinking under
these drugs you can't think at all you
can't even move because you're
anesthetized under these drugs you can
think very very differently in alcohol
by the way what you're the one drug
you're allowed to use legally in this
country is a bit more like these than
these it kind of makes you gives you
rigidity rather than flexibility of
thinking
thank you
foreign
[Music]
so William Jameson in this book I
mentioned uh
classifies it in four ways ineffability
you can't explain what's going on uh by
noetic quality which means in the
experience itself you feel like it's
real vertical when you come out of it
you might not feel that anymore you
might feel okay that was weird but
completely mad right
um but in the experience itself there's
a feeling of reality transiency he said
these things past maximum two hours of
course this was before LSD uh 12 hours
and uh passivity which means you lose
agency you lose your ability to change
things you know you are at the mercy of
the influx of experience which is
partially you know true to a certain
extent I think another way of defining
mystical experience from Bertrand
Russell is great essay mysticism and
Logic for criteria not quite the same he
says mystical experiences are intuitive
and revelatory rather than rational or
intellectual
um in other words you don't work them
out they just come to you
um he writes this there's always this
sense of unity so this was not in
William James just but Justin Russell
pantheism and religion one isn't
philosophy and he talks about the
unreality of time being very common and
the intra very interesting with regards
to ethics the unreality of Good and Evil
Octavia Paz also spoke about this he
said psychedelic drugs take you out of
your cultural ideology and your Notions
of Good and Evil and make you see them
from afar
um a form of nihilism in a way I mean he
went to prison for his pacifist work of
course both from Russell so he was a
moralist in one sense but it's
interesting how
um arguably psychedelics can pull you
out of your culture
arguably and my kid that's what my
accuser said you know about the
political
um expedience of psychedelics anyway
there's another
um definition of mystical experience now
will it Walter stay throughout this very
uh influential book in 1960 called uh
mysticism and philosophy where he has
seven criteria for uh the mystical State
now this was very influential in
creating the hood mysticism skill which
is used in clinical trials today
but a lot of people say it's not it's
not good enough you know but anyway what
is it so it talks about there's
introvertive and extrovertive mysticism
introverted is basically eyes closed
extrovertive is more like nature Mr
system the kind of Mr Zuma maybe uh the
Romantic poet spoke about like
Wordsworth especially so those are two
broad categories and then he talks about
the unitary Consciousness the one void
pure Consciousness that has many words
uh names
um he talks about non-speciality
non-temporality and introvertive only a
sense of objectivity or reality what
James calls noetic quality blessedness
peace that's new feeling of the Holy the
sacred or Divine
um Philly a paradoxicality so it's like
for example you might be here there at
the same time something might have been
in the past in the future or the past
future existence wants that kind of
paradoxicality and uh alleged by Mystics
to be enough ineffable like
Indescribable once more even though he
describes it here and writes book but
now so that's one view of mysticism but
there is an interesting debate that is
has been going on for a number of
decades since 1978 really
um which which really maps onto new
psychedelic
um
philosophy and science really which is
this perennialism as against
contextualism
[Music]
that brings us on to this interesting
discussion that was had in the 1960s and
it's beginning to pick up again between
contextualism and perennialism
and the argument very basically is there
are certain thinkers
perennialists the epitome of that's
probably old as actually uh perhaps
William James as well who argue that um
amongst all religions and or all Mystics
amongst all religions and also amongst
psychedelic experiences there is one
um there's one Ultimate Experience which
transcends all culture and is the same
it says the interpretation which differs
so I interpreted as phoneticism U.S
trinitarianism someone else in another
way perhaps But ultimately the
experience is the same that's compared
contrasted to contextualism which is the
argument that your culture and your life
fully determine the experience so for
example in um in the west we are prone
to see Jesus and um and the burning bush
or whatever whereas in the in the
Americas you're more prone to see
Jaguars and snakes and whatever right so
what's your take on this and there are
midpoints as well do you think
do you think psychedelic experiences are
determined by one's culture or do you
think there's something beyond that that
they Point towards
well I think some aspects of them take
us way beyond our own culture I mean
when I first took LSD around 1971
um the I'd be an educated in a
completely mechanistic way I was at the
time I'd been converted to atheism by my
science teachers I was in Cambridge I
was a Don at Cambridge when I took it
and I was you know I'd been to
physiology lectures I knew about
neurotransmitters in the brain and and
so on and I took LSD and this was so off
the map of anything I'd been taught or
told about except for reading Aldous
Huxley that I didn't interpret it
exactly in the context of the culture I
knew because it was not on that map
um it's more on that map no but um the
but there's a there's an aspect of which
takes us beyond the realms
cultural names and forms and so on and
what do you think that experience so
that's tends towards a perennialist a
Viewpoint what um
do you think I mean how would you
distinguish between hallucinations
because obviously some forms of
psychedelic experience the more visual
ones are hallucinatory
um and others are not well how would how
do you think one could go about
determining whether one's hallucinating
or actually gaining access to some
metaphysical realm Beyond what's offered
through materialism
well let me come back to the
contextualism thing because I actually
have a take on that but this it slightly
depends on my own theory of morphic
resonance and so I can't spend half an
hour explaining it but very briefly it's
the idea there's a collective memory
there's a memory in nature there's a
resonance from similar systems in the
past to the present so if a lot of
people in the Amazon take Ayahuasca in
shamanic cultures where it's all about
jaguars and with particular mythologies
serpents Jaguars and so on then if
westerners come along and take
Ayahuasca the same kinds of changes are
going to happen in their brain which may
put them in resonance with those who've
taken it before and so there may be a
culturally shaped Collective memory of
the Ayahuasca experience which affects
people who don't come from that culture
at all and when Claudio naranjo a
psychotherapist gave
Ayahuasca to middle-class people in
Chile and Santiago who'd never heard of
Amazonian Jaguar Cults they had visions
of jaguars and things so I don't think
it's because there's molecules in the
brain that respond to dimethyltryptamine
and create Jaguar images inside the head
I think it's because they were picking
up on a kind of collective memory
through morphic Resonance of the
culturally impregnated experience
so we're currently going through the
so-called psychedelic Renaissance
so-called why do you think psychedelics
are becoming popular now in many fields
um once more what what do you ascribe to
this Renaissance
I think because they're opening up
people's minds to this much larger Realm
of the mind for exactly the same reasons
that I've found them so liberating and I
think for many people they're a kind of
rite of passage out of a shrunken
materialist world view into a wider view
of consciousness
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]